how do you keep the audience guessing
and surprising them with plot twists
the only feature of the two you could
apply that to i think is restraint
in terms of that's it's suspense driven
in a sense and there's
i wouldn't say withholding there's just
you know letting the audience
figure it out for themselves but i like
using negative space and i like
leaving things to people's imagination
and
giving them just enough you know like if
you show the foot you can see the rest
of the
the person you know somehow and i think
it's more i think it's stronger when
you're left to imagine it
um i mean certainly that's true in
in with restraint you know that some
violent things happen but i don't like i
don't
really want to show that stuff or i
think the more graphic you are the less
powerful your film becomes
so does that does that speak to what
you're
what you're asking me i think so writing
dialogue
what's your approach to writing dialogue
i sometimes will
speak as the characters so i can
understand their point of view
mainly so i can understand their point
of view in the scene
and then occasionally i'll get some nice
pieces of dialogue from that
but just understand the way people talk
understand that there's so many
different things that have to do with
the way a person talks
whether it's where they're from
you know how they're feeling that day
their weight
you know all kinds of things um
[Music]
stress you know sexuality
that go into it and um but once you know
your characters
it just comes seems effortless and then
the other thing is just remember
that don't like there is nothing more
boring
than listening to characters explain
themselves
well maybe that's an approach i don't
know it's more like what not to do than
what to do though
so the characters in turmoil
don't don't don't explain it show them
going through some kind of an emotional
breakdown but they don't need to
[Music]
verbalize what they're going through
sometimes they do
yeah sometimes they would sometimes we
would as people i don't know but um
yeah i don't know i mean it depends on
the situation but i i found it
to be a lot stronger to imply
or to
just let people figure it out because
it's usually you know everyone
is kind of on the same page but um
how do i show someone in turmoil i mean
it's like don't the last person you're
going to feel for is the person that
says oh i'm in turmoil
you know it's like you want to see it
and then you're like oh are you
okay
and and i think that that's part of it
you know when an actor
it's like when an actor holds back
emotion it's it's more powerful than
you know seeing seeing them weep or you
know
get really emotional on camera when
they're trying not to
that's what we do in life very true you
know and i think it's it's stronger
how do you get to know your characters
just i mean through
through time sometimes it depends on the
characters sometimes there's
some sort of archetype you're working
with um sometimes you're
you're borrowing from life and maybe
you're borrowing from a few different
places
um but really in in the same way you get
to know the world of the film
just by thinking about it marinating
writing it out
you know doing whatever your process is
i mean time
has a lot to do with it um
[Music]
yeah it's just to me just a natural part
of
writing anything you know you don't you
know very little at first and then every
element
reveals itself over the course of time
have you ever written a character where
you feel like you're you're not dialed
in enough to them
and then you've totally changed the
character or maybe made them a
supporting character
and not the main one
[Music]
yeah probably i don't know if it would
have been because i was i didn't think i
knew them well enough
um not for that reason but
certainly you know they uh
will kind of tell you what their role is
to
to some extent not sure if i'm answering
the question but um
yeah they just uh sometimes
i mean sometimes they go away entirely
you know and you'll have this whole
character that you wrote out and you
realize this is redundant
or superfluous in some way or it doesn't
work or maybe it works for another film
you just have to be really honest about
it do you think that filmmakers or
writers
should stick to one genre no no i think
that's the word i mean
if that's what you want yeah why not
but i think there's a thing where you
know in recent times of getting
relegated
to a certain genre because you did that
and you did it well
and you should you know it confuses me
that you want to do other things
but i think the great filmmakers
the really great filmmakers work across
all genres
and they're you know kubrick is a good
example
i mean you can do war you can do horror
you can do suspense
you can do comedy
just be the you know do it do it well
well what about people who kind of
create their own
sort of genre or their own style like
tarantino you know
okay that's very tarantino like this
type of scene
this dialogue whatever this car driving
with this music in the background
yeah those are those those people are
the best and then david lynch's and the
and the clintons of the world and
i'm glad they're out there i'm really
glad they're out there and i'm glad
they're
being allowed to do their thing
and do you think that
if an artist is considered great but
then
they don't get that accolade from the
top of the top that says
you are a great artist but somehow the
collective thinks that they are
what do you think that's about the
collective
the collective what meaning moviegoers
cinephiles
artists but that those artists don't get
um
validated at what like at the oscar
level or things like that
i mean that i think that's pretty
typical
it happens all the time i think
you know again i mean i guess that's
important to some people
you know how they're perceived and you
know
accolades things like that um
i just i've never really thought that
way never really it's never really been
about that for me
i mean how you can't control how you're
perceived anyway
right and once you think you you you
have a handle on that you really
don't so i say just give that up
and
do your do your work to the best of your
ability
do you think people have fought against
that in you like you talked about
letting go
and and you're not in things for the
accolades
do you think that that stirs up things
in people
relative to myself yeah no i mean anyone
who knows me
very well knows that i don't really care
about that stuff so i mean i appreciate
it
believe me i appreciate you know if
anyone has something nice to say or if
anyone sees something i've done which
you know it's not a lot of people but if
they do and it moves them in some way
that's
rewarding enough that it reached
somebody
you know
you